When a blockbuster movie is just months away,
fans can't resist dissecting the trailers
and TV spots for hints of what to expect.
But even casual fans will want to catch these
Easter Eggs and awesome details in popular
trailers.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Amazing Hidden Details
In Popular Movie Trailers.
Deadpool
When the first test footage leaked, fans of
Deadpool related so strongly, Fox greenlit
the movie immediately.
One of the creators of the oddball assassin,
Rob Liefeld got a shout out in that test reel,
but the movie's trailer took a different route
- literally.
Eagle-eyed fans can catch both names of co-creator
Fabian Nicieza marking road signs in the background
of the trailer's freeway fight scene.
Batman V Superman
The first face-to-face meeting between Clark
Kent and Bruce Wayne showed that Gotham's
caped crusader doesn't have much respect for
Superman, or the disasters he helps solve.
It's a common example, but it isn't random.
It's actually a nod to the first Superman
movie, when Christopher Reeve was seen doing
exactly that.
Another interesting nod is hidden in the shots
where Superman lifts a russian rocket with
the number “300” on it.
It’s a clear reference to director Zack
Snyder’s other epic movie, “300”.
Star Trek Beyond
The fact that the Enterprise is actually shown
being torn apart in the first trailer for
Star Trek Beyond rubbed some fans the wrong
way - but it also marooned Kirk and the crew
on an alien planet.
The crew's solution may actually be given
away thanks to a song choice: "Sabotage,"
by the Beastie Boys.
Scotty might not know the tune, but Trek fans
do.
It's the same song Kirk played when he stole
his uncle's Corvette in the first movie.
Since the crew seems to be stealing a new
spaceship, Kirk can't help but realize the
coincidence.
Captain America: Civil War
In the pages of Marvel Comics, Captain America's
friend Bucky didn't stay a sidekick for good,
eventually taking the shield and title in
Steve's absence.
The first Captain America movie showed Bucky
wielding the shield as a nod to that fact,
and again in The Winter Soldier.
Civil War keeps the trend alive, with Bucky
handling the shield in a fight with Iron Man.
Whether he takes the Captain America role
in the movies... remains to be seen.
If that wasn't enough, the trailer also shows
a subtle upgrade to the Iron Man armor.
Fans can catch a glimpse of the suit's helmet
Disappearing behind Tony Stark's head.
It may just be a way to easily get Tony's
face on screen, but the idea of a flexible
suit of armor plates will instantly have fans
hoping for the Bleeding Edge nanotech armor,
which is actually stored inside Tony's body
in the comics.
But we wouldn't hold our breath on that one.
Independence Day Resurgence
Fans of the original Independence Day had
hoped that Will Smith would return for the
sequel, but before the movie started filming,
it was confirmed that his character, Captain
Steven Hiller wouldn't make an appearance.
But the first trailer delivered a nasty surprise,
when the website built for the trailer’s
release showed us a timeline of events, one
of the moments explained his absence.
Killing off the first movie's hero isn't a
crowd pleasing solution - but it does the
job.
X-Men: Apocalypse
With brand new mutants being introduced or
reinvented in X-Men: Apocalypse, it's easy
to see why fans might miss some small details
from the trailer.
For starters, the brand new, futuristic uniforms
may keep fans from noticing that Quicksilver
has apparently joined the team, after a brief,
but unforgettable scene from the previous
movie.
There is another cool easter egg in the shot
where Apocalypse is seen entering a dark room,
the bald character is none other than Caliban,
of the Morlocks, that Bryan Singer decided
to bring to the big screen.
Warcraft
Fans of the Warcraft video game series didn't
know what to expect from a movie version,
but the first trailer showed it was mostly
the mythology of the franchise that would
be adapted.
But one game easter egg made it through.
The fields of Westfield shown in the trailer
aren't being farmed by humans, but mechanical
harvest golems, pulled right from the starting
zones of World of Warcraft.
Those are the trailer moments and Easter Eggs
we caught, but which details from your favorite
trailers have we missed?
Let us know in the comments, and be sure to
subscribe for more videos like this one.